presumably you and Kylie have met before
yes John and Daisy no I did imagine Lane
I didn't eat you I did I met you a BAFTA
yeah yeah yeah I tried to take self
through the managers bit starstruck
Lane seven the rest of the sofa can just
relax because guess who's here
guess who's here who's here sexiest man
alive
do you do they phone you when kind of oh
by the way you're the sex men like they
do phone you actually and say that
you're you know up for winning it and
you know I was obviously very surprised
and slightly embarrassed especially when
my son just turn around to me was like
really so yeah it was slightly
embarrassing but obviously I'm very
proud of it as well I might did you not
know you're in there that's what the
sexiest man alive you're in the running
yeah you're in here you're down as
sexiest stormtrooper what no one told
you that I mean it's not the biggest
deal in the world that's the biggest fan
of the world yeah yeah come back to us
when you're on the cover and I suppose I
have to ask you David because I we're
minutes of all the Star Wars stuff Star
Wars big fan of course I mean when I was
10 years old I mean Princess Leia was
always for me
[Applause]
ten years
there were three foams or three films
[Music]
you